los ensayos para el desfile militar del
14 de julio en parís ya están en marcha
este año 9 países miembros de la otan de
europa del este serán los protagonistas
de la ceremonia un guiño a la guerra que
asola a ucrania
la guerra está regresando completa y
cruelmente en suelo europeo y nos
recuerda las tragedias de la historia
ahora re descubrimos que la fuerza moral
de nuestra nación debe ser absolutamente
cultivada fomentada y desarrollada
los soldados son un símbolo de la
cooperación militar franco rumana pocos
días después de la invasión rusa ucrania
en febrero 500 soldados franceses y 300
belgas fueron desplegados en rumanía
como parte de la fuerza de reacción
rápida de la otan los miembros del
vigésimo séptimo batallón de francia
mostraron su orgullo tras regresar de
una misión en el país
esto marca el punto culminante de los
cuatro meses que hemos pasado allí
terminar nuestra participación en
rumanía con un acontecimiento como el 14
de julio es importante salsas como pocos
participan búlgaros húngaros checos
polacos lituanos estonios letones y
eslovacos el ejército francés considera
que esta cooperación militar es una
forma de garantizar
la seguridad se trata de mostrar algo
más que las celebraciones nacionales
nuestra unión y cohesión nacional para
mostrar este mensaje específico de que
hoy el ejército sirve para defender al
país al defender a rumanía que se
enfrenta a una expansión del conflicto
estamos de hecho defendiendo a francia y
a la población francesa si la
procuración cosas se espera en más de
6.000 participantes para el día de la
bastilla de este año la solidaridad
europea también está presente en el
cielo los aviones rafale griegos se
preparan para sobrevolar parís